how was tampa dude tampa was good man
ebor
ebor right no uh i think it was like
i think carrollwood or something like
that i i can't side splitters yeah
sideways i don't know what yeah i don't
know what it is
i don't know where side splitters at
it's not even no e-boards were you down
anymore though
no i stayed in my room oh you didn't
venture out anything no
by myself yeah dog well because
it's so spread out to where it's like
too like
i don't know like i would have to like
take an uber yeah take an uber to some
[ __ ] and that was like i don't
really feel like doing it or something
yeah which by the way after the map
yeah yeah what does it say uh
so when lakes hot town houses curl wood
it's just like they call it carol
freaking lakes yeah
um which by the way that owner brian
thompson
good time it's a g he's like right on
the
like he don't play around with nothing
like you know like there's some clubs
where you go to
and like people start talking and the
club is like
nightmare scared they're scared to do
anything about it
not him he's right on it he hey you
talking too much
he'll tell you himself he does it
himself oh damn yep he watches
was there security there no he just did
it oh he's he's he's he's doing security
oh he's a big dude yeah big dude he's
like are you like
six five six six [ __ ] he played
football he's that he actually he's from
uh
akron on the board he played basketball
he's a lebron
he's older than lebron yeah they used to
play like uh not like
too much older but like yeah lebron was
i think he was a senior lebron was a
freshman or something like that he
watched lebron
lebron yeah he played with lebron as
much as i did oh
how do you know you don't know this
guy's story i know this guy don't know
his story if he's the manager of a
comedy club
and he's loving his life right now and
i'm sure he's killing him i'm just
saying he played as much basketball
lebron
from akron ohio oh okay i don't want to
say he doesn't play ball though
all of her all i heard was six five
listen and he dropping he coming up are
you too loud i'm not gonna say anything
bro do you have any hecklers uh no
because he
he was pretty damn quick actually there
was one it was actually
sunday night the last show talk that
talk i was talking about i said i was
talking about something about michael
jackson
all right in r.i.p and this girl
um this guy was like oh i can do the
moonwalk drunk dude up front i was like
white guy oh yeah i was yeah i was like
okay cool respect
yeah you know what i mean usually like
if they shout once i don't really like
god i don't just go oh cool respect and
then his girlfriend's like do it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] straight up to the man to meet
you
no to her to her so she wear the pants
in a relationship
there's some rednecks oh my gosh she
said you had [ __ ]
and the crowd was like they had an
argument in the car and then did she get
did he no he
uh i think he left her there oh white
yeah like a g
like was she was she hot or she like oh
like a mullet that's what i picture i
think i think chabelle don't look at
that yeah just regular white chicken
yeah regular white girl do it [ __ ]
yeah he's like get up and do it no he
didn't get up his face turned
red dude she felt so bad did she look
like yeah i was like man i told her
i told the staff i was like man can i
get him a drink like one of them little
[ __ ] drinks that's what i said
i said that i added on to yeah
that's the pineapple juice oh yeah i was
like i said sex on the beach or
something like that
i think that's what i was embarrassed
yeah dude she was so aggressive about it
did was it a decent hotel yeah it was a
nice hotel one of them hilton's how did
she say it though like was it regret
like dude
no do it [ __ ] yeah you got it right god
damn well
are you friends with my stepfather [ __ ]
if you need to calm down
so aggressive it was the weirdest [ __ ]
ever how did she laugh at any point of
the show she was
she was having a good time she was
really drunk i'll copy that she was
really aware during your hours since
you've been doing like 15
20 minutes oh yeah yeah but it was you
know it was actually like good
i did a lot better than i actually
thought because i was like you know i
i barely started my first first
headlining gig
was um back in october of uh last year
2019. so i just started like getting
these headlining dates
the first headline gig was in
indianapolis minneapolis uh yeah
minnesota yeah
yep so that was my first one comedy yeah
house of comedy
and then you know i think in february
like my last like headlining gig was
somewhere in reno i did oh i did this
uh casino gig and then everything then
everything after that just started
dropping
started dropping covert came in yeah and
then so i yeah i haven't done
45 in a minute but like i was going
through mapping it out in my room and it
it worked out well i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah got this [ __ ] back
up home yeah you know it was it was
great it was great i had it i had a good
time
when i got off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together come on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son